the National Institutes of Health
predicts that this year's flu season
will be rough last year Americans
reportedly spent nearly 6 billion
dollars with Abby on remedies for runny
noses and sore throats over-the-counter
medications can have risk high doses of
acetaminophen sent nearly 60,000 people
to the emergency room every year in its
January issue Consumer Reports looks at
how to survive this cold and flu season
a little easier Lisa Gill is deputy
content editor for The Magazine and
joins us at the table boy am I glad
you're here today Lee thanks so much for
having me on I will put the tip on my
throat so I know something's coming so
before I go to the drugstore because
what I do is order everything make
nyquil might well yeah they're sudafed
sudafed everything and you're saying be
careful about what you get over they
absolutely you know we did this report
because we found in a national survey
and also secret shoppers that we sent
out across the country to pharmacies
there are too many products and what is
on those products is very confusing and
chief among them is acetaminophen we
found this I think and everything it's
in everything and not only that the
surprising risk about it it's a really
safe drug when taken up to the maximum
daily dose that the FDA tells us four
thousand milligrams but the surprising
thing about it is just a little bit more
than that and it starts to put you at
risk for liver toxicity that's what
that's why so many people go to the
emergency room liver damage and liver
failure so be very careful about how
much acetaminophen you take that's the
first thing second thing to other drugs
I just love to mention oxymetazoline
this is a really common nasal spray used
for nasal congestion I like it because
it actually really works and it also
works faster than tablets but don't use
that drug for longer than three days
that's on the package label already but
you know it's working so well you just
think you actually then lose your sense
of smell and your sense of taste well
yeah and not only that it can actually
make your congestion worse after that
that three days so just be very careful
about the timing and the last thing is
Believe It or Not allergy medications
lots of people use allergy medications
like satirises een diphenhydramine
fexofenadine loratadine to treat runny
nose and cough from a cold but research
tells us they will not work for that
they really only work there work really
well for seasonal allergies but not for
cold and if it's ever worked for you
it's probably
I mean this report is like it just seems
like a must read in terms of going to it
um you also look at home remedies that
are backed by science so which of them
work exactly so we were happy and
surprised to find out
chicken soup does double duty yes you
know homemade and even just like Adam
but here's the thing it provides
anti-inflammatory effects that's the
thing that makes you have like you know
body eggs you know it's that's like the
worst part of having a flu gets rid of
that also the warm liquid helps ease
congestion and a sore throat other two
things saltwater gargling with warm salt
water helps with sore throat and even
nasal rinsing with a neti pot or sprays
very good finally honey this is my
favorite you can eat honey right out of
the jar like I like to do or you can put
it in a warm drink like I could like a
tea honey reduces the coughing yeah and
it doesn't in kids too this is a really
great thing for kids just don't put it
don't give it to babies under age of one
okay what about the loading up a vitamin
C yeah it seems like it's a good idea
and I totally understand the thing is so
much vitamin C puts you at risk for
kidney stones which are really really
painful it vitamin C the evidence shows
us that it might reduce the duration of
a cold but our suggestion is to get
vitamin C through your diet leafy greens
and citrus and kind of skip the
supplements because kidney stones are
really no fun all right chicken today I
want to see that recipe on your
Instagram gotta find that alright Lisa
Gill thanks so much thank you